what is this story behind the song
you're singing today throw me a party
ok so throw me a party I wrote with the
amazing songwriters Liz rose and
Kristian Bush yeah from the band
Sugarland and a few years ago you know
you kind of hear the words that you
never ever think you're gonna hear that
you ever want to hear which is you have
cancer and I found out that I had breast
cancer and had a bilateral mastectomy
and I'm a survivor sitting here today
talking to you so interesting because
when you're going through something like
that and you really don't know what its
gonna be like and how it's gonna turn
out and you don't know if you're gonna
be sitting here yeah kids and you kids
and yeah I wanted to have these very
serious discussions with my husband and
I said to him look if if something
happens and I should go before you then
I just want you to know that there's a
couple things that I want one is that I
want you to be super sad for a really
long time like I will haunt you a few
days then the second thing was that I
wanted a party I wanted to have a
celebration and I wanted to have a lot
of singing and dancing and people
telling stories and and to feel like
that was being celebrated and so the
song came out of that I had the title
yeah and wrote it with Liz and Christian
and it's great thank you like I was
telling you there I've never heard a
song and I Melissa - all the time like
and also perfect for their heart it's a
hard thing a funeral I've had to sing at
funerals I don't know if I do that for
it's the worst thing ever
don't say yes and it's just the worst
thing ever and and it should be
sometimes I feel like we're this culture
that we just get so depressed but it is
a very depressing thing but at the same
time like celebrate the life that was
live exactly and that's what I love
about the whole lyric it was so perfect
there's gonna be time there's gonna be
crying and there's gonna be sad that's
okay
and you never ever forget you know a
person you never do I think about my mom
and dad every single day yeah so there
in fact my five-year-old is literally
learning about death right now just cuz
she kind of was seeing something I'm
like you're five this is a hard
conversation but I keep telling her I'm
like even if something ever never no
mommy I'm never really gone because you
were in me and like
we're part of each other and so I'm
always present and it's like really hard
you find yourself kind of talking
yourself through death like while you're
trying to tell your child that's exactly
right I'm trying to kind of wrap your
head around your own mortality and
that's the weirdest thing but I have to
say that in some ways and I don't know
if there are survivors or people who
have had struggles in the audience but
in some ways cancer was a blessing like
it really taught me to live every moment
to the fullest and every moment as if it
was your last like we don't know what
tomorrow brings we have to be able to
live and go out today going wow okay I
did it and everything that I wanted to
do I live the life that I wanted to live
today subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going